jarquín la segunda ciudad más grande de
ucrania está siendo la más atacada por
la artillería rusa escuelas hospitales
guarderías están siendo sistemáticamente
bombardeadas ya que la frontera se
encuentra sólo 40 kilómetros y las
tropas rusas están rodeando a unos 16
kilómetros esta ciudad más del 50% de la
población ha huido ya peloto 50 resiste
en esta ciudad bajo los bombardeos
diarios
las sirenas
teniendo que estar en muchas ocasiones
en los sótanos de las casas o incluso en
las líneas de metro las tropas rusas no
han conseguido tomar kharkiv y es por
eso según dicen aquí que su forma de
revancha es atacar la ciudad diariamente